and the crows very special to me because
in my first the western movie I did not
speak English again and also especially
work very close with Brendan Lee you
know what happened a movie and everyday
was sitting literally next to each other
and he's teaching me play video games
and the funny things he he said that he
asked me are you Chinese I said yeah he
said I'm Chinese are you kidding me
because I didn't know him so now he said
yeah my father's Chinese I say Oh what
do you what'd your father do is this my
father's famous actor I say oh what's
his name he's there Bruce Lee I said I
don't know who that is huge
you don't know probably you're one of
the only person in the world doesn't
know so I did not know a father I feel
bad I were shooting in North Carolina
I call my friend in New York I said you
know who Bruce Lee's old my Chinese
friend see yeah it's a leash alone but I
did not speak English so I did not learn
and never learned both free I only know
the Chinese demolition next day come to
missile of course I know he was no
wonder but it's really really mystical
experience but make me realize how
beautiful filmmaking is because no
matter where you are but you're always
there at the moment unscrewing it is
fascinating it's really in we're lucky
to be in this kind of art especially in
Hollywood and a movie like admired all
over the world by everybody see talking
about being immortalized on film I mean
which of the movies that you've made
would you most like people to remember
you for and obviously gonna make more in
the future but at the moment
well like red corner and another key
that's my actually one critical words
like a National Board of Review which is
from credit I think they're very moving
very solid the very feminine many levels
of emotions that I give and I touched
people's hearts that's something I think
I like to do because it's through art
you help others encourage others you
give compassion love of course like
wah-wah was cranked to the crow and
other my baby study other films where
captain and including a French film I
did
haxe III with Luca song they're all fun
like oh like entertainment like crank -
I was crazy but it's fun the spirit is
just joy you give to other like The Lost
entourage and I only did one episode of
leech but people love me for and they
remember that because so strong impact
because those two issues are very
popular and very well written and so I
was lucky to be part of it so those are
people talk absolutely different people
are recognize different things I
I say of course a lot of people
recognize me also from Anju and Star
Wars of course towers like big big and
also at that times very controversial
because I was appear the first Asian
woman at cover Playboy magazine and was
the film star was released same time
severe controversial so but I'm very
fortunate I worked with two biggest
culture I come from us Hugh Hefner
George Lopez I feel like I'm very lucky
how can I have this laugh to work with
the two icons in the world I just feel
I'm very humble in this way and feeling
I'm lucky and grateful
you